[Musik]
Milliarden Kubikmeter Wasser strömen
unkontrolliert durch den zerstörten
kachowka Staudamm im russisch besetzten
Gebiet aus Angst vor den Wassermassen
flüchten die Menschen aus dem
betroffenen Gebieten im Süden der
Ukraine die Evakuierungen laufen seit
den frühen Morgenstunden schon jetzt in
mehrere Dörfer überflutet und das Wasser
steigt weiter eine Umweltkatastrophe
mitten im Krieg
herzlich willkommen zu einem zdf-spezial
die Rosenheim-Cops verschieben sich um
ca 10 Minuten
von einer neuen Dimension im Krieg gegen
die Ukraine spricht Bundeskanzler Olaf
Scholz die Ukraine selbstwirbt Russland
Staat Terrorismus vor von der größten
menschengemachten Katastrophe seit
Jahrzehnten ist die Rede Moskau wiederum
bestreitet alle Vorwürfe und beschuldigt
Ukraine
waren schon seit Monaten Russland könnte
ein Anschlag auf den Staudamm planen
über die Zerstörung und die folgenden
jetzt muss jeder auf der Welt kraftvoll
und schnell handeln um einen neuen
russischen Terroranschlag zu verhindern
eine Zerstörung des Staudamms wurde eine
Katastrophe großen Ausmaßes bedeuten
[Musik]
aus der Warnung des ukrainischen
Präsidenten vor acht Monaten wird
Wirklichkeit seit den frühen
Morgenstunden strömen Wassermassen
unkontrolliert in den flussnipro der
Damm des kachowgas zerstört der
Wasserstand des stauses singt Zentimeter
für Zentimeter besonders schnell kam das
Wasser in die Stadt novakarovka die
direkt am Staudamm liegt und von
Russland kontrolliert wird insgesamt
sollen mehr als 80 Ortschaften von den
Überschwemmungen bedroht sein seit
Stunden wird die Region evakuiert
ich bitte Sie Dokumente und das
allerwichtigste mitzunehmen und auf die
vakuierungsbusse zu warten ich bitte Sie
alles zu tun um sich selbst zu schützen
und ihr Leben zu retten verlassen sie
sofort Dinge fahren Bereich
nur mit dem Nötigsten verlassen Menschen
in der Region Presse und ihre Häuser
eine Region die ohnehin hart umkämpft
ist ob und wann sie wiederkommen können
ist ungewiss
das sind die Kinder meines Bruders meine
Neffen und Nichten ich versuche nach
kommischani zu kommen was da los ist
weiß ich nicht unsere Mutter ist da wir
gehen erstmal hin weil es dort etwas
höher ist
für die Ukraine steht fest Russland ist
für die Zerstörung des Staudamms
verantwortlich Präsident silensky
spricht von Terror geht davon aus dass
der Damm von innen heraus gesprengt
wurde doch Moskau bestreitet das weiß
der Ukraine die Schuld an der
Katastrophe zu
eine Katastrophe deren Ausmaß niemand
abschätzen kann schon seit Monaten
fordern die russischen Besatzer Menschen
auf die Region zu verlassen nun gehen
wohl alle und was aus ihrem Zuhause wird
ist unklar denn das Wasser fließt weiter
ungehindert aus dem Stausee
ja über den Umweltaspekt reden wir
gleich noch jetzt sprechen wir erstmal
mit dem Sicherheitsexperten Christian
Mölling guten Abend hallo guten Abend
beschuldigen sich ja gegenseitig der
Zerstörung der Staudamms was halten Sie
denn für wahrscheinlich
in der Tat wir haben zurzeit noch keine
eindeutige Informationen aber ich kann
mir nicht vorstellen dass die Ukraine
irgendeinen Grund gehabt haben sollte
diesen Staudamm zu zerstören es hat
militärisch keinen Vorteil und vor allen
Dingen die Menschen die davon jetzt
betroffen sind sind die eigene ist die
eigene Bevölkerung es ist das eigene
Land das die Ukraine damit unter Wasser
gesetzt hätte das macht aus meiner Sicht
nicht wahnsinnig viel Sinn ich glaube es
ist sehr viel plausibler anzunehmen das
Russland versuchen wollte ukrainische
Streitkräfte davon abzuhalten über
diesen Fluss überzusetzen im Rahmen der
Offensive und dass man dafür ein Loch in
den Staudamm springen wollte und dass
das möglicherweise außer Kontrolle
geraten ist denn es sind auch russische
Verbände und russische Stellungen jetzt
betroffen von dem was da gerade passiert
schon an welche Auswirkungen hat denn
der Bruch der Staudamms für den
Kriegsverlauf und die ukrainische gegen
Offensive
das wird schwer zu bewerten sein weil
ich glaube in der Tat dass man mit
dieser Situation auf beiden Seiten nicht
wirklich gerechnet hat ich glaube dass
man eher versucht hatte auf russischer
Seite kontrolliert das Wasser zu erhöhen
jetzt haben beide Seiten eine neue
Situation diese neue bewerten müssen von
daher ist es ein überraschungselement
das beide Seiten trifft die Ukraine ist
gleichzeitig jetzt ganz stark damit
gebunden die humanitäre Katastrophe die
sich jetzt abzeichnen auch die
Umweltkatastrophe einigermaßen in den
Griff zu bekommen das heißt das wird die
Ukraine nebenbei mit beschäftigen oder
jetzt erstmal den nächsten Tagen
überhaupt Punkt sein wie dann sich die
Verhältnisse mit Schlamm mit kadawern
auswirken auf die Möglichkeit vor Ort
militärische Aktivitäten abzuhalten das
wird noch etwas dauern bis wir das
besser einschätzen können ja und was
würden Sie sagen haben wir jetzt hier
wirklich mit einer neuen Dimension des
Krieges zu tun
der Bundeskanzler hat das ja in zwei
Richtungen einsortiert also ich glaube
dass man einfach sehen kann dass die
russische Seite nicht mehr in der Lage
ist offensichtlich militärisch überhaupt
noch in irgendeiner Art Weise zu
eskalieren so dass man zu Mitteln greift
die durch das Kriegsvölkerrecht
hochgradig verboten sind und die in
keinem Verhältnis stehen zu dem was hier
gewonnen worden ist das heißt also im
Grunde genommen haben wir es mit einer
Kontinuität zu tun Russland greift
ständig in eine Kiste die nichts mit
normaler Kriegsführung zu tun hat und
ist bereit Menschenleben systematisch
offensichtlich zu opfern
vielen Dank für die Einschätzung
Christian
russland hat eine ökologische Massen
vernichtungswaffe gezündet so der
ukrainische Präsident selenski was
bedeuten die Überschwemmungen für die
Umwelt in den vermieten Kriegsgebiet für
die so wichtigen ernten die
Stromversorgung und für das nahegelegene
Atomkraftwerk saporicia
für das Kernkraftwerk saporicia gab es
schon kurz nach der Explosion am
Staudamm Entwarnung keine unmittelbare
Gefahr twittert die Internationale
Atomenergiebehörde Überschwemmungen wird
es dort nicht geben allerdings das
Kraftwerk braucht Wasser zur Kühlung aus
dem Stausee trotz Sinken der Pegelstände
ist das wohl kein Problem die Kühlung
erfolgt über sogenannte sprühteiche die
also nur ein bisschen ersatzwasser
brauchen was auf jeden Fall zur
Verfügung steht schwieriger wäre es wenn
ich jetzt vor hätte das Kraftwerk wieder
in Betrieb zu nehmen dann brauche ich
schon gewissen Pegelstand am Kraftwerk
um ausreichenden kümming zur Verfügung
zu haben aber das steht ja aktuell nicht
so Disposition das Kraftwerk liegt etwa
140 km Fluss aufwärts vom staudammt von
den schweren Überschwemmungen betroffen
ist das Gebiet westlich davon eine
Katastrophe für die Menschen aber auch
für die Umwelt ukrainische
Umweltschützer werfen der russischen
Armee bewussten Öko zieht vor
der Schaden für die Umwelt ist massiv
und schwer alles Land die Fruchtbarkeit
des Bodens auch die Ressourcen des
Waldes und des Wassers die Flora und
Fauna sind völlig zerstört und manches
ist unwiderbringlich verloren
aus einer Raffinerie soll auch Öl in den
Fluss gelaufen sein das könnte die
Schäden noch verschlimmern ebenso wie
zehntausende überflutete Landminen und
Munitionsdepots die ukrainischen
Umweltschützer glauben es wäre Jahre
dauern bis das Land wieder nutzbar ist
und Milliarden Euro kosten
[Applaus]
und in der Ukraine bin ich verbunden mit
Simon Schlegel Ukraine Analyst einer
internationalen Denkfabrik der den
Staudamm und die Region gut kennt Herr
Schlegel wie bewerten Sie die Folgen für
die Umwelt
ja es wäre jetzt nicht jetzt riesige
Wassermassen aus diesem Staudamm den
Unterlauf des Niveau runter Richtung
Delta das ist eines der größten und
naturbelassensten Fluss Deltas Europas
auf dem Weg wird der Fluss alles
mitreißen was ich in den Weg stellte so
aus Industriegebieten Aussiedlungen aber
eben auch sehr stark aus diesem
Kriegsgebiet das ist eines der stärksten
vermieten Gebiete der Welt auf beiden
Seiten weil dort ja schon seit Monaten
eben eine eine Angriff der Ukraine
erwartet wird deswegen haben die Russen
dort sehr viele Minen vergraben aber
auch sehr viele Munitionslager ein
angelegt und beschießen sich gegenseitig
seit Monaten mit Munitionen all das wird
vom Wasser mitgetragen werden wird auf
einem großen Gebiet verteilt werden und
wird die Aufräumarbeiten deswegen ganz
besonders gefährlich machen wen trifft
dieser Dammbruch denn besonders hart
am härtesten trifft es die Menschen die
trotz des Krieges seit 16 Monaten dort
aushand das sind oft Menschen die keine
andere Wahl haben die vielleicht sehr
stark von ihrem Garten leben von vom
kleinen viel Leben dass sie nicht
zurücklassen können die vielleicht
älter sind oder eine Krankheit haben die
sie Tiere Mobilität einschränkt diese
Menschen haben auf bessere Zeiten dort
gesagt dass der Kriege vorbei geht dass
die jüngeren Menschen zurückkehren in
ihre Dörfer das wird jetzt viel länger
dauern weil viele dieser Dörfer jetzt
zusätzlich zerstört werden und
vielleicht auch gar nicht alle diese
Menschen rechtzeitig von dort fliehen
konnten und was ist ihre Meinung nach
die größte Gefahr
kurzfristig ist die größte Gefahr diese
sind diese riesigen Wassermassen die
alles mitreißen auf lange Sicht hinaus
ist die größte Gefahr in diesem Gebiet
dass es zu einer nachhaltigen Zerstörung
der Infrastruktur kommt dieses
Elektrizitätswerk wird wahrscheinlich
nicht mehr wieder aufgebaut werden dass
Atomkraftwerk das sich ja aus dem
Stausee speist wird sehr wahrscheinlich
nicht bald wieder ans Netz gehen können
das heißt es fehlen ökonomische Chancen
auch in der Landwirtschaft die in diesem
Gebiet sehr stark von Bewässerung
abhängt das heißt falls die Ukraine
Gebiete zurückerobert kann kann es gut
sein dass es hier nicht gelingt dort
wirtschaftliche Chancen zu schaffen und
auch dazu zu sorgen dass die Menschen
zurückkehren können und welche Folgen
glauben sie hat das für den weiteren
Kriegsverlauf
kurzfristig denke ich gibt es gar nicht
so große folgen natürlich haben beide
Seiten
gefechtsstellungen in Gebieten angelegt
die jetzt überflutet sind zum Beispiel
auf Inseln im nibro Delta aber vor allem
auch am linken Ufer wo die Russen sich
sehr tief eingegraben haben das ist das
tiefe Ufer das sandige Ufer des Nepper
dort
müssen sie müssen die Truppen sich sehr
viel weiter vom Flussufer zurückziehen
bis sie trockenes Land erreichen das
heißt die die Stellungen verschieben
sich etwas die erste Verteidigungslinien
der Russen ist wahrscheinlich jetzt
unter Wasser
langfristig aber geht es eben vor allem
darum dass dieses das gebietet seine Art
verbrannte Erde er fährt es
entzieht diesen Gebiet wirtschaftliche
Chancen und
verhindert eine erfolgreiche
Eingliederung falls die Ukraine dieses
Gebiet zurückerobern
vielen Dank für diese Einschätzung
wir haben das Gespräch haben wir kurz
vor der Sendung aus technischen Gründen
aufgezeichnet das war es von uns mehr
zum katastrophalen staudammbruch mitten
im Krieg später im heute journal wie
geht es jetzt weiter mit den
Rosenheim-Cops auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]